what is organic chemistry as opposed to
normal chemistry so chemistry in general
is split up I guess into like three
major sections okay I could be wrong on
this but like my understanding is like
uh inorganic chem organic chem and then
physical chem okay so physical chem is
basically physics it's like the
intermediary between the chemistry right
because chemistry is a lot of physics is
a lot of chemistry yeah in a way well so
it's like the moment you start doing
stuff that requires I say physics so
it's like you can have some chemical
reactions
um require lasers so it's like it would
be all of like the people who are doing
laser stuff are usually the Fizz
chemists and they do a lot of um
actually I don't even know too much
about fizzcam just I know that when
you're in organic chem which is what I
did yeah
um you always just say that fizzcam is
boring and you feel bad for everyone
who's in it but I don't actually really
know
just could you take a picture well you
take a few Fizz chem classes it's all
thermodynamics uh you're doing a lot of
like like just calculations
um so what's the difference between
chemistry and organic chemistry so the
organic and inorganic is basically the
difference between carbon and non-carbon
there is like a crossover right but like
organic just in chemistry is just carbon
based so anything any chemistry
involving like the braking or
modification or building of
carbon-carbon bonds or carbon
and is that a lot of things in most
things it's a lot but the thing is that
like any chemistry you do with like
nitrogen or Metals so like iron copper
so if you take acid and pour it on
copper that's inorganic chem because
there's no carbon involved so like
people generally they'll Branch off
into the tube usually like people go
like I do inorganic inorganic chemistry
primarily or organic but there is a
crossover where people can do like
um a lot of catalysts are inorganic so
people like that's the lab that I was in
when I was doing my grad studies it was
kind of even weirder too because it was
like it's inorganic things inorganic
molecules so it's like a very big
crossover and then you catalyze organic
reactions but a lot of catalysts like
copper metal just copper metal can you
you can use to catalyze
yeah I remember mechanic reactions right
right right so it's like there is a bit
of crossover between the two oh God you
give me like PTSD from chemistry a level
but a lot of people who spec out an
organic chem will then know not like do
you get very much into organic chem yeah
and then you know you know enough about
inorganic it's like your thing requires
it but it's a very different chemistry
and then the people who know all about
the inorganic stuff will then be much
fuzzier about the or the carbon based
stuff so how did you get into like
chemistry at school like presumably
after the blowtorch I mean I at this
point it just feels like natural right
yeah you're obviously very knowledgeable
now but like how did it go from being a
crazy kid in the backyard to getting a
formal education yeah because you said
you wanted to go to the veterinary right
yeah so like how did it go from
Veterinary to just doing the chem stuff
so I'll I'll pick up where we left off
sure after I was making flash powder I
quit I I never made it I don't know why
I think it coincided at some point with
like a fear of firecrackers right yeah
and I was like I just want to blow my
fingers off so I just and since then I
don't like explosives like I just kind
of stopped yeah but
I got I really want to make thermite
[Music]
okay which you know thermite is it's the
[ __ ] that bones like ridiculously yeah
right yeah yeah and so it's like
aluminum and iron oxide yeah so
everything that's dangerous so I really
got into like making the rust okay to
make it and then trying to make aluminum
powder I kind of like I think it kind of
worked once I've actually never set off
or my huh I just kind of had no success
in that realm okay okay but
I guess I call I've always like just had
like a lot of the I always say the
projects I really liked just happened to
be chemistry right right right so when
you went to school and they were trying
to teach you all this boring [ __ ] were
you like oh that's easy I did that like
when I was two no so like around that
time I was doing chemistry in high
school and I got like 65 I thought I was
gonna fail the class and I remember
being really scared because I won't get
into the science program right in my
with Stage happens which basically like
it's in just before University right
yeah we have something called uh sixth
forms okay two years right yeah yeah so
I just was like I didn't really care
about the theory yeah so I didn't really
study I just didn't really understand or
care right
um well you're not blowing anything up
right you're not not dissolving anything
why would you care no I'm not in any
immediate danger
I don't know I just I don't remember
having any like strong thoughts about it
yeah I just kind of always but my dad
was has a background inside so growing
up was always like I'm a science guy so
I just should do well in this like I
didn't think too much yeah
um and then going into sejab I also I
didn't do well in chemistry it was
actually my worst science subject right
I kind of hated it um
I just didn't care for too much Theory I
guess but I got to do organic Camp right
and I don't know why it's like so I
described it as like a game it's very
much like once you know the rules
I liked in my head like picturing how
the molecules would move around and like
how to build things that's what I liked
about organic yeah and like solving the
problem to me was satisfying right that
makes sense yeah yeah so I just I just
liked the idea of organic chemistry and
I like the idea that you could like
have things and you could build other
things out of it with your knowledge
right I thought it was cool
um so I thought learning about different
reactions was just interesting yeah
right uh but up until then I still
hadn't done like any
real chemistry
um until University
um what constitutes is real I did I'd
say I did nothing okay
um I wasn't I really want to do like
filmmaking stuff like it was had nothing
to do with well now you combined the two
yeah well that's exactly so it is
related so I got obsessed I think it was
in like 20
12. I got obsessed with spicy food and I
really wanted to extract pure capsaicin
from peppers
because I was just like I wanted that
explains the interaction we had in La
yeah we met you yeah so we we had a
little get-together at our Airbnb and
then Nigel turns out and uh whips out a
vial of pure capsaicin he's like hey you
want to try some and so he pulls out a
needle and gets it out what unsharpening
what does that mean I I have this great
footage of Nigel preparing it all right
we're putting on the gloves I could hear
them yeah yeah I I remember just like
having a drink chilling outside just
like having a nice little chat I come in
and [ __ ] Nigel's not just got a
needle out and putting [ __ ] on a
violence it sounds like some Horrors it
looked like a horror I was like yo you
what what kind of [ __ ] drugs are we
shooting up for this party one like I
know we're in LA but come on guys come
on your cap station which I don't know
if I would I don't know if it would be
less insane if you guys were just doing
drugs because at least it wouldn't make
sense he was wearing gloves as well yeah
so just was like even more concerned
when I first this so this is like kind
of relevant ah whatever I was I'll just
go back okay I was obsessed with spicy
stuff yeah yeah and I don't know why I
went through a phase I'm like if it's
not spicy I don't want to eat it yeah
fair enough and I wanted to taste pure
capsaicin I don't know why so what I
started just like trying to extract it
but I was too poor to afford gloves so I
would do everything without gloves oh my
God I'd be like pouring solvents and so
my hands you could get these solvents
but you couldn't get a [ __ ] pair of
gloves acetone from like the hardware
store like gloves are cheaper than that
they were like 20 a box or something at
the time like 15 a box
I think I had I think I had negative
money in my bank account right the
solvents were like my dad's garage sale
okay okay um
so I got I would get it all over my
hands all the time and I would touch my
face so I got like that's why I told you
I got super used to just like
capsaicin oh my gosh
but again that was another like science
project that I didn't really
care that it was like it's kind of
heavily chemistry yeah
so I'm like reading all these forums on
how to like do extractions and like
chromatography and like all this stuff
I'm like I just want pure capsaicin all
right this time I didn't succeed I think
it was about 50 what I had okay right
okay did it taste it was spicy that
stuff you gave me
yeah and it was pretty spicy it wasn't
like it wasn't as crazy as I thought it
was gonna be I because I gave you guys
like I
I didn't know how you guys handle it and
it's like if I gave you you could get an
amount that looks like nothing but it
like the next 30 minutes depending on
how you handle spice like you might
think it's gonna ruin your entire night
I handle spice pretty well and I'd say
it was it was it was definitely spicy
but it wasn't like
the amount that I gave people and I was
like if you're good with spice you'd be
fine yeah yeah the world test is if Joey
ever does it which uh we're wearing up
in the hospital probably I mean I've
gotten better you have gotten better I
used to be like zero tolerance right
yeah you know the this year I had a
ghost pepper for the first time I would
say that's worse on it it all is the
dose right yeah so it's just like I find
actual fresh peppers like really spicy
peppers are probably worse than what
you'd have with uh with capsaicin right
even though it's really concentrated
yeah it doesn't really spread around
your mouth
everywhere so like honestly like those
spicy Wing challenges are like worse
your all your lips are burning like it's
so and then you're hiccuping and like
the next day your stomach just hurts
yeah whereas like you don't get that if
you have like um capsaicin there's so
little it doesn't even irritate yourself
although you say that but I remember
specifically when you were giving a
little bit of the Pure Cafe you were
just like don't swallow it because
you're freaking me out because you're
like don't swallow okay don't swallow I
give it some people and it's like they
Panic oh yeah so I was trying to be like
I'm not going to give you a lot like if
you don't like it don't panic just spit
it instantly you're whipping this out
and giving it to people when back in the
day when I was like doing it at home
like when I extracted myself it was like
anyone who would
you you're a man
I haven't asked the important question
why did you have a vial of cap station
just yeah just in your bag and what else
do you have in your bag that you just
carry around
there's a reason because like for one of
the videos I was making a spicy compound
and so I brought it a very small amount
the last time I was in LA right yeah but
I just kind of like I didn't bring
enough I didn't like set it up properly
so it's kind of a disappointment so when
I came back I was like I'm gonna bring
spicy stuff again but it had been like
six months or seven months right I
didn't have the other stuff anymore the
stuff that I made right so then I I was
just like I'm just gonna bring how does
like TSA react to stuff like that when I
guess they didn't see it yes
I just hope they don't know can't hurt
them right yeah I guess so it's not
illegal or anything like you know it
just I remember
put it together as a kit to make it look
sketchy
did you want it to look sketchy I
thought it was funny yeah yeah I mean it
also was the only way I could package it
yeah but it's even the little plastic
bag I had like I purposely I thought it
was funny yeah um definitely looked like
a mad scientist just like whipping this
thing out